okay [ __ ] okay we're back at it it's
a more psychobabble with Donald sharp
right here and we are gonna do with a
quest called road to fredo what is that
turn the [ __ ] off no no no no okay we're
gonna follow the freight on trial ok
batches where is that ok yeah good god
oh god it god I in and Daniel Chad ondol
I get papi que papi ok so let's do this
let's do this now the best way the
socket deck is to try to find her
freedom trail ok that's tennis ok i'm
here i'm at the trail ok i carefully i'm
following it i can't i'm following it
following it ok I'll following it ok ok
good good good oh [ __ ] ok
hey I should just start on that side
side okay gets a little muddled here's a
lot of [ __ ] here looks like [ __ ] feli
honestly it really does you're gonna
chat at them and Phil I do this [ __ ] all
over the road is that how it's gonna say
dang it's gone this way right that [ __ ]
up [ __ ] now that's why is ok please sir
don't like a hurt you yes as Jesus
ok hello trying to find the freedom
trail there ok ok oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah I'm here all right shut fuckin'-a
which way are we good who's that ok
again ouch Eiffel for that I'm here to
find the freedom trail
yeah okay where was I last here now that
we need to see they going this way maybe
just going this way I'm check
and then let's see anything that looks
like the pope [ __ ]
anything that looks that the reader
found out this is their own pocket way
that is for sure it's gone this way so
it's probably gotta get gotta go through
here right there we go
okay good good good is it is that the
freedom trail 3 I can't [ __ ] so I had
to go more okay today's s J's s good
good
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] good how [ __ ] far
out is a site oh [ __ ] my white ass hole
why you got kills [ __ ] no no no no no
no oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I don't you remember
one less my [ __ ] saved was it's gonna
be [ __ ] disaster on a fast forward
okay I'm back guys I'm back up [ __ ] what
the hook shot on over there okay okay
it's why this way what the [ __ ] she says
I forgot to go for this thing I'm
leading in some panties may be so funny
if it just literally just [ __ ] led to
a pair of panties in an alleyway that'd
be like the funniest joke I've ever seen
and of course its creator ma hi oh [ __ ]
really follow me in I don't know oh no
and I guess not ok ok that's like a
[ __ ] here's the other one
[ __ ] am I supposed to go why is it
telling me not to go here is this not
the right place let's go on here come on
come on takes like 10 years allowed come
on come on her daddy
Oh Jess take half the plate at a second
loaf and check on the right safe trail
ends right to church okay I go back in
all right it's doubly in here
okay it just says any hidden goals in
here is that good good just take a good
luck here cuz I didn't really take a
good look last time you know no se
brother existence you know okay
disgusting disgusting disgusting yeah
yeah you know it's all pretty girls okay
okay okay okay
God hello I'm here to a hey the joy is a
[ __ ] is this
so let's
it's over here okay okay okay the [ __ ]
the game plane is here but it looks like
the entrance here is not God okay
hmm okay
let's start with honor I
now have to start over
well
pair out
okay where's the day wears a day got
good good good good good good good oh
yeah oh yeah yeah quick save this batch
right I'll tell you bet but before we go
any further answer my questions who the
hell
yeah yeah why don't you tell me who you
in a world full of suspicion luxury and
hunt I followed if that's true sure who
told you how to copy cat nap eh I just
heard a rumor I see I'm Desdemona Deegan
where have you been you're having a
party what gives with my invitation I'm
not like his glasses on a lot glad
someone know you know you're practically
does the silver shroud mean anything to
you I heard he took out oh yeah and uh
railroad owes you a crepe pal a
truckload of Nuka Cola for what you holy
[ __ ] so you're about chin for him yes
trust me that changes things mm-hmm I'd
like to find answers are the only ones
fight I'd like to say that nobody comes
here out for blood uh-huh we need to
hurt anyone else amen to that if we're
going to be dealing with you I need to
make sure we're on the same page yeah
good the Institute treats
that sounds exactly so we seek to free
the since from I have a question the
only question that matters right yes yes
once well said you were right about us
we're the only band we could use more
but right now we don't have the time to
treat and in turn queen ok let's go
faster so quick